bonjour à tous et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur public sénat pour
découvrir ensemble les travaux de la
commission d' enquête du sénat sur le
thème l'école et les valeurs de la
république
cette commission d'enquêté a été créée à
la fin du mois de janvier à la demande
du groupe ump au lendemain des attentats
meurtriers de ce début d'année les
sénateurs s'efforce de répondre à une
question comment faire ou refaire de
l'école le creuset des valeurs de la
république la commission multiplie les
auditions et les déplacements dans les
établissements scolaires vous propose
aujourd'hui est bien de revoir l'une des
auditions qui s'est tenue ce matin celle
de jean michel blanquer directeur
général du groupe essec et ancien
directeur général de l'enseignement
scolaire au ministère de l'éducation
nationale
il insiste notamment sur l'apprentissage
de la relation à l'autre
dès le plus jeune âge et sur
l'importance de la relation avec les
parents d'élèves
on découvre tout de suite en audition
son diagnostic et ses propositions mais
chers collègues nos débutants nos
auditions d'aujourd'hui en recevant
monsieur jean michel blanquer
ancien directeur général de
l'enseignement scolaire actuellement
directeur général du groupe essec comme
la loi le permet votre audition fera
l'objet d'un compte rendu publié dans le
recueil des tableaux des tables donc là
ce matin des travaux des commissions qui
est diffusé en version papier sur le
site internet du sénat docteur et agrégé
en droit public vous avez enseigné à
l'université pendant une quinzaine
d'années avant d'être nommé recteur de
l'académie de guyane en 2004 puis de
l'académie de créteil en 2007
de 2009 à 2012 vous avez exercé les
fonctions de directeur général de
l'enseignement scolaire au sein du
ministère de l'éducation nationale avant
d'être nommé anges
et 2013 directeur général du groupe
essec vous avez récemment publié un
ouvrage intitulé l'école de la vie dans
lequel vous livrer votre diagnostic sur
le système scolaire et réaliser un
certain nombre de préconisations tiré de
votre expérience
c'est au titre de ce riche parcours au
sein de l'éducation nationale que la
commission a souhaité vous entendre afin
de recueillir votre analyse sur l'état
actuel de la transmission des valeurs
républicaines à l'école vous pourrez
sans doute éclairer nos travaux sur les
menaces qui pèsent sur notre système
scolaire et sur les solutions envisagées
pour refaire de l'école le creuset de
notre république
avant de vous passer la parole le
formalisme des commission denquête me
conduit à vous demander de prêter
serment
je suis également tenus de vous indiquer
que tout faux témoignage devant notre
commission serait pas si des peines
prévues aux articles 434 13 à 434 15 du
code pénal
en conséquence monsieur je vous invite à
prêter serment de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité levé la main droite
et dit je le jure je le jure je vous
remercie
selon l' usage habituel je vous propose
de nous faire part de vos observations
durant une dizaine de minutes après quoi
notre rapporteur jacques grosperrin et
les membres de la commission qui le
souhaitent pourront vous poser leurs
quartiers leurs questions vous avez la
parole vous madame la présidente
bon je voudrais dire que je suis
évidemment honoré par par votre
invitation et est heureux de pouvoir
partager avec vous quelques analyses
puisqu'il s'agit peut-être du sujet le
plus important qui soit puisque pour
pour toute société
l'éducation est le sujet le plus
important qu'ils soient qui détermine le
long terme qui détermine l'unité de la
société et donc c'est évidemment très
important qu'il y ait des principes
républicains partager et que dès
l'enfance on s'en préoccupe
puisque c'est à ce moment là que
beaucoup de choses se détermine donc je
suis heureux de pouvoir partager ses
analyses vous avez fait référence
à ce que j'ai pu faire dans l'éducation
nationale et puis à ce livre l'école de
la vie où justement je traite un peu
cette question je traite en fait
beaucoup cette question soit directement
soit indirectement
pourquoi est ce que je dis directement
ou indirectement c'est parce que par
définition tout est systémique dans le
domaine de l'éducation c'est à dire quel
que soit le sujet que l'on aborde il
aura un impact sur le sujet qui est le
vôtre aujourd'hui
autrement dit c'est multifactoriel si
par exemple je parle de programme de
français d'histoire géographie ça a
évidemment un impact sur sur le sujet si
je parle de la relation avec les parents
d'élèves ce que je vais faire d'ailleurs
serna on a un
etc etc etc de la formation des
professeurs même du statut de
l'établissement tout tout est systémique
tout est interrelié donc parler de cela
oblige évidemment avoir une vision
d'ensemble même si je vais pas en dix
minutes
brossez toutes les toutous tout cela je
partirai donc de l'élève et de son
parcours pour dire que mes yeux on peut
considérer que le sujet déjà à deux
dimensions
en gros une dimension de relation à
autrui c'est à dire qu'on peut résumer
par le respect d'autrui
et puis une dimension de relation à la
vie collective à l'institution à la
république et qui est donc le rapport à
la république le rapport mais qui pour
un enfant évidemment passe par
l'institution qui représente la
république c'est à dire l'école et ces
deux dimensions évidemment sont
complémentaires mais on peut les
distinguer sur le premier point c'est à
dire la relation à autrui qui évidemment
est une autre des façons de définir la
morale qui est il question toujours de
respect d'autrui
là ce sujet est aujourd'hui éclairé de
manière différente de ce que l'on
pouvait savoir il ya encore quelques
années je crois que c'est important de
le dire ce n'est pas un sujet statique
le
il est démontré par les sciences
cognitives qu'il ya un potentiel
d'empathie de l'enfant qui est
extrêmement fort enfin deux donc de
l'être humain et que d'ailleurs si on
n'y prend garde on peut inhiber ce
sentiment d'empathie et même d'ailleurs
certaines perversions peuvent
s'expliquer par cette attention
potentiel d'empathie qui a été inhibés
et inversement si on tire parti de cela
on peut réussir à faire des enfants de 0
à 6 ans des enfants qui ont le sens
d'autrui le sens notamment de ceux la
capacité de se mettre à la place
d'autrui
je crois que ce point est très important
parce qu'il est à la fois pratique et
théorique il est anthropologique et
pragmatique
pourquoi anthropologique parce que
finalement on peut dire que parfois les
débats sur le système scolaire ont
hésité entre deux de paul et qu'on est
en train d'en trouver un troisième c'est
le deux pôles c'est le pôle premièrement
le pôle rousseauiste l'homme n'est bon
mais c'est la société qui le corrompt et
puis un autre pôle plus pessimistes qui
se dit dans l'homme n'est mauvais dix
ans et c'est la société qui par
l'éducation va le ramener à aa se
corriger je pense qu'il ya une sorte de
troisième voie de ligne de crête assez
scientifiquement fondées consistant à
dire loeb menait avec un potentiel
d'empathie considérables et c'est
l'éducation qui va permettre de le
révéler de l'affirmer de la ceci nous
renvoie donc déjà deux sur tout ce qui
se passe de 0 à 3 ans donc qui excède
notre sujet d'aujourd'hui mais qui est
quand même très important ou de 0 à 2
ans si l'enfant entra à 2 ans à l'école
en tout cas que se passe-t-il d'un point
de vue familial et social entre 0 et 3
ans est évidemment essentiel puisque
nous savons notamment que lorsque
l'enfant arrive à l'école maternelle il
ya déjà des germes d'inégalité entre les
enfants qui peut qu'il se voit au
travers par exemple du vocabulaire
maîtrisé et le nombre de mots que
maîtrisé à l'âge de 3 ans est déjà assez
prédictifs de vos réussites scolaires
futur ce qui ce qui signifie qu
évidemment le bain familial ajout a joué
un rôle tout ce qui permet d'avoir et or
on sait toujours pour rester sur la
question du vocabulaire qu'il ya un lien
direct entre vocabulaire et violence si
vous êtes un
en difficulté pour exprimer ce que vous
avez exprimées si vous n'avez pas une
certaine subtilité de penser elles mêmes
liées à votre étendue de langage et bien
ceci a un impact sur vos comportements
et donc ces sujets là sont déjà à la
base essentielle et suppose d'avoir été
pris à bras le corps ce qui suppose donc
un programme de maternelle sujet sur
lequel il ya eu de grands progrès depuis
une douzaine d'années il faut le
signaler puisque ont soumis une souvent
les mauvaises nouvelles mais il y en a
une très bonne dans le paysage de
l'éducation nationale qui est passée un
peu inaperçue qui est que entre 1998 et
2011 une étude très précise du ministère
de l'éducation sorti l'année dernière
montre que l'enfant aborde le cours
préparatoire avec plus d'atouts que donc
il ya dix ans autrement dit aujourd'hui
enfin en 2011
un enfant de d'employés ou d'ouvriers a
autant de chances mesurée par le
vocabulaire la phonologie et c'est que
un enfant de cadre en 1998 comme il ya
souvent des statistiques pour nous dira
l'un vers sur d'autres sujets je me
plais à dire cela parce que on peut le
dire que par delà les gouvernements par
delà les les les soubresauts qu'il ya pu
y avoir sur le plan de surtout en
politique il ya quand même eu des
continuités de politique éducative
notamment pour considérer qu'il fallait
une politique de la de la maternelle une
petite de la maternelle cd programme de
maternelle une vision spécifique de cet
âge là et cette vision spécifique donc
c'est non seulement des programmes assez
volontariste et là le sujet à ce stade
n'est plus forcément consensuel parce
que on va avoir souvent d'un côté on
doit plaider comme je suis en train de
le faire pour une attention très précise
à certaines compétences de l'enfant à la
maternelle et parfois on va opposer à
cette vision l'idée que la maternelle
c'est fait pour s'épanouir jouer chanter
et c'est bien entendu de nouveau je
considère qu'il ya une troisième voie
qui consiste à dire que bien entendu les
deux vont ensemble c'est à dire que
c'est par le jeu le langage la musique
la musique qui est tellement importante
c'est un sujet non négligeable dans dans
vos travaux
tout cela joue un rôle à la maternelle
mais doit avoir une visée pédagogique
précise qui est une visée de
socialisation de l'enfant
et puis autre conséquence de tout cela
donc au delà de la dimension je dirais
cognitif c'est lorsqu'on apprend à
l'enfant
il ya la vision complète de l'enfant et
de ce point de vue là dès la maternelle
et bien entendu c'est vrai pour la suite
ne pas faire de distinction entre ce qui
se passe dans la classe et enfin en
faire une méthodologique mais pas
éthique si je puis dire entre ce qui se
passe dans la classe et ce qui se passe
en dehors de la classe notamment dans la
cour de récréation quand vous avez un
enfant persécuté par les autres dans la
cour de récréation quand vous avez des
phénomènes de tous ordres d'exclusion de
l'autre de non respect d'autrui
et bien c'est déjà le germe de quelque
chose d' éventuellement graves et
l'éducation se passe par là quand on dit
cela ça renvoie à la responsabilité de
la communauté éducative c'est à dire
l'idée qu' on ne peut pas considérer que
être un professeur aujourd'hui c'est
simplement venir dans la classe fait
recours et s'en aller il ya évidemment
d'abord et c'est pas non plus un
individu face à un groupe d'élèves
c'est une communauté d'individus reliés
à une communauté d'élèves et les
individus sont d'ailleurs les
professeurs mais pas seulement les
professeurs l'ensemble de la communauté
adultes qui travaillent dans
l'établissement et tous ceux qui les
aident autour de l'établissement et
comment ceux ci donc comment cette
communauté prend ses responsabilités à
une vision complète de ce qui se passe
pour l'enfant du début du début à la fin
donc j'insiste sur cette première
dimension c'est à dire le le respect
d'autrui qui est une vision optimiste de
l'homme une vision volontariste de
l'éducation que l'on que l'on peut
promener en commençant par l'internet
mais vu le temps dont on dispose je
n'insiste pas plus là dessus puis
deuxièmement le
les valeurs de la république les valeurs
de l'école adhérer à la collectivité
adhérer à la communauté adhérer à pays
auquel on appartient
je pense que c'est une évidence que
l'être humain a besoin de cela l'être
humain a besoin d'appartenir à des
cercles concentriques d'appartenance à
commencer par sa famille et bien entendu
la nation compte beaucoup dans ce dans
ce cadre là paradoxalement la france qui
est un peu on peut considérer comme l'un
des deux ou trois pays qui ont inventé
cette notion de nation est celui qui a
le plus de complexes vis-à-vis de cela
peut-être que nous sommes parce que
justement nous sommes âgés sur le sujet
mais fatigué sur le sujet alors même que
ça ne pose aucun problème dans beaucoup
de pays et jean c'est une expérience
internationale assez forte pendant les
années que vous avez rappelé j'étais
notamment sur le continent américain où
j'ai vécu en amérique latine notamment
et aux états unis
j'ai aussi une expérience outre-mer d'où
les choses se pose différemment et le
met tout ce que j'ai vu c'est évidemment
une absence de complexes vis-à-vis de
cela c'est à dire que le celui ou celle
qui arrive en disant il faut aimer son
pays
en aucun cas n'ait vu comme un
personnage archaïques ou réactionnaire
c'est au contraire la chose la plus
naturelle qui soit et qui fait partie
d'une chaîne d'appartenance qui n'exclut
personne qui au contraire est à
inclusive
donc je pense que cela fait maintenant
longtemps trop longtemps que
l'atmosphère générale de notre pays et à
oublier cela et on en paye évidemment
les conséquences comme recteur j'ai eu
l'occasion de très souvent évidemment de
prendre un chemin inverse de de dire à
quel point c'était important donc dans
le livre je donne quelques le livre
évidemment écrit avant le 7 janvier donc
j'ai pas de je pense qu'il n'est pas il
n'y a pas besoin d'attendre ce qui s'est
passé pour pour comprendre qu'il y avait
qu il y avait un sujet le 7 dans d'olive
un des exemples que je donne des vins
parmi parmi beaucoup d'autres et celui
de la marseillaise que l'on qui a été
donc dans les années 2000 quand il ya eu
ces quelques scandales autour du fait
qu'elle était sifflé au stade de france
on avait organisé dans l'académie de
créteil entre des enfants du val de
marne seine saint denis et et de
seine-et-marne
une chorale pour chanter la marseillaise
au début de des matches de l'équipe
d'alors de l'équipe de france de rugby
en l'occurrence mais ça aurait pu être
de football et ça s'est passé ça a eu
lieu malheureusement une seule fois
j'aurais aimé que ça se perpétue dans le
temps mais en tout cas à la fois
l'exercice en lui-même qui a une nature
musicale avec toutes les vertus que ça
représente mais l'exercice républicain
et le ce que cela a signifié ce jour là
dans le stade quand vous aviez cette
centaine d'enfants qui chantait il n'y
avait pas une seule personne qui a
imaginé siffler ça à ce moment là
évidemment le c'est un exemple parmi
d'autres mais où évidemment il faut une
vie avoir une vision joyeuse
constructive optimiste incluant tu de la
nation et qui passe par un état d'esprit
qui ensuite se traduit par toute une
série de choses concrètes
au travers de cet exemple je pense qu'on
peut dire que la question de
l'instruction civique n'est pas du tout
un sujet des huées bien au contraire
après c'est la façon dont c'est fait la
façon dont s'est relié aux enjeux de
morale donc une instruction civique et
morale qui donc distingue les deux
dimensions mais mais les relient entre
elles en montrant bien que derrière la
question du respect de la république qui
alla respect d'autrui aussi évidemment
et et l'adhésion alors par rapport aux
aux enjeux d'intégration que l'on que
l'on met souvent en avant sur ces
questions je voudrais d'abord souligner
à quel point j'ai vu très souvent dès
que la grande majorité des enfants issus
de l'immigration en réalité adhèrent aux
valeurs de la république et son ac et
surtout très enclin à rentrer dans dans
les logiques que positive que je viens
de citer mais que ce qui se voit c'est
évidemment là la minorité importante de
2 200 e ou celle pour qui ça n'est pas
le cas et je pense que un pays qui
n'affichent pas une certaine fierté une
certaine joie dans le fait de faire
communauté régulièrement mais de manière
assez naturelle
évidemment ne risque pas de créer ces
phénomènes d'adhésion eux-mêmes naturel
que l'on a dans son pays et si on se
compare par exemple aux états unis où
les conditions des immigrés sont pas
forcément meilleurs qu'en france on s en
faut la fierté qu'on réussit à créer se
passe par pas passe par des éléments
symboliques et état d'esprit général que
l'on qu'on pourrait retrouver en france
surtout que ça correspond à une
tradition française qui existaient bel
et bien donc c'est pas si difficile que
ça de la delà de la retrouver et c'est
quelque chose qui évidemment transcende
les clivages politiques
donc le jeu je pense que peut-être pour
conclure le ce qui est important aussi
c'est l'image que donne le monde adulte
au monde des élèves
lorsqu'on se plaint des phénomènes de
violence il faut bien se ou de divisions
au sein des communautés d'élèves
il faut bien se rendre compte que la
première chose c'est le sujet de
l'exemplarité c'est à dire que se
passe-t-il que voient les élèves
alors c'est vrai aussi de ce qu'il voit
en dehors de l'établissement ce qu'ils
voient dans leur famille ce qu'ils
voient à la télévision sur internet etc
mais c'est aussi vrai de ce qu'ils
voient dans l'établissement s'il voit d
une communauté adulte soudé si un
professeur qui se fait chahuter n'est
pas un individu seul mais quelqu'un qui
qui est pour lequel ya une solidarité
des professeurs une équipe en face ce
phénomène ce sera si si c'est juste de
l'individualisme dont ils sont témoins
au quotidien tout le temps sous toutes
les formes et évidemment eux-mêmes
cultiveront cela et puis on peut même
avoir un danger de basculement d'une
société adolescente
supérieurs en quelque sorte se sentant
plus forte que la société des adultes et
là évidemment toutes les débordements
sont possibles ça existe parfois et
c'est aussi cette unité du monde adulte
qui est importante dans l'établissement
scolaire
merci pour cet exposé très clair et ceux
qui n'ont pas lu votre livre vont se
précipiter pour le lire et je vais donc
donner la parole un autre à porter
jacques grosperrin merci présidente je
voudrais merci monsieur jean michel
blanquer air donc de devoir accepter
cette invitation notre invitation parce
que il a toujours au sein de l'entente
créateurs mais également en tant que
directeur l'enseignement scolaire su
apporter des solutions novatrices dans
dans beaucoup de difficultés qu'ont
rencontrées et c'est vrai que certains
mettant dans ce conte préfet de dire
c'étaient des petits matins des petites
touches qui faisait comment donner vous
pouvez faire évoluer le monde de
l'éducation nationale qui est difficile
à faire évoluer changer parce que c'est
une grosse structure mois avant de
laisser la parole à mes amis mes amis et
collectionneur je voudrais vous poser
trois questions vous vous en avez
envisagé une j'aurais souhaité coup le
prolonger ou le développer la première
c'est le diagnostic d'une dégradation du
climat scolaire
c est ce que c'est un effet ressenti est
ce que c'est une réalité souvent liées
aux manifestations d'appartenance
religieuse au sein des établissements
vous parait-elle où vous paraît-il
pardon justifier plus largement pensez
vous que l'école soit confronté à une
remise en cause de sa mission
d'intégration et de formation des
citoyens
c'est ma première question la deuxième
est ce que les valeurs républicaines
vous vous lavez
vous l'avez décrit dans vos propos
liminaire mais ce que vous pensez que la
valeur des républicaines vous semble
suffisamment et cliquez à l'école est ce
que le contenu des enseignements
l'organisation de la vie scolaire au
sein des établissements vous semble-t-il
adapté à l'accomplissement de cette
mission vous avez parlé également
peut-être si vous pouviez prolonger
votre votre pensée par rapport à
l'introduction à la rentrée prochaine
anciennement morales et civiques et
enfin une troisième question c'est face
à ce qui s'est passé mais c'est vrai que
cette mission a été créé et pas
seulement à cause de cela c'est aussi
parce qu'on a voulu un mois données
s'interroger sur sur les valeurs
républicaines à l'école beaucoup
d'enseignants nous ont dit ne pas se
sentir suffisamment préparés soutenus
par leur hiérarchie
elle c'est vrai que les chefs
d'établissements et les corps
intermédiaires l'éducation nationale au
premier rang les inspecteurs d'éducation
et ce qu'ils ont un rôle privilégié
particulier spécifique à jouer quelles
seront mes trois questions avant que mes
collègues puissent intervenir sur sur la
dégradation du climat scolaire
il ya souvent des études des chiffres
sur ces questions je langer en plus moi
même je ne suis pas en ce moment même au
ministère donc je suis certainement pas
la personne la plus à même de parler
d'une dégradation récente du climat
scolaire
je pense de façon générale il ya il ya
eu des on observer certaines
dégradations à la fois sur le plan
pédagogique et sur le plan éducatif à
mon avis plutôt vers les années 90 une
sorte de trou d'air qui depuis on est
plus sur un sur un plat si je puis dire
c'est en tout cas le sentiment que le
sentiment que j'ai et ce plat est à un
niveau 2 de violence relativement élevés
auxquels il faut prendre garde donc fort
est documenté ce que je suis en train de
dire l'étayer mai mais c'est en tout cas
la
l'analyse que je pouvais faire sur un
certain nombre de sujets je ne voyais
pas au long des années 2000 une
augmentation de la violence mais je la
voyais installé à un niveau qui qui
était déjà à regarder deux a regardé de
près même si évidemment il ya toujours
une part inévitable de violences dans
tout dans tout système néanmoins on peut
considérer que quand on pourrait faire
qu'on pourrait faire beaucoup mieux
est-ce que de ce fait on a des remèdes
appropriés par rapport à cela
là dessus je voudrais peut-être souligné
deux ou trois choses d'abord
l'importance de la relation avec les
parents d'élèves
c'est un c'est un sujet essentiel dans
toutes les études internationales on
montre très bien que dans les dents les
trois facteurs principaux de réussite du
système scolaire
il y à la relation parents elle comment
est-ce que parents professeurs pardon
comment est ce que un système scolaire
réussi à associer les parents au système
et surtout dans quelle mesure il ya t'il
convergence des valeurs entre la famille
et l'école
ça a beaucoup été dit après les
événements de janvier que il ya les
failles pas non plus chargées l'école de
tous les maux de la terre que bien
entendu beaucoup de choses mais c'est en
dehors d'elle et de ce point de vue là
là la communication entre parents
établissement est essentiel et ce n'est
pas un point fort du système français on
le sait bien pour des raisons
historiques bien connus parfois si j'ose
dire pour de bonnes et de mauvaises
raisons
mais le fait est que ce n'est pas un
climat de confiance qui existe
aujourd'hui
c'est d'ailleurs l'habitude de
considérer que ce mot de confiance et le
mot clé parce que quand on fait
référence au passé parfois avec
nostalgie la troisième république en
particulier
et souvent répond à cela mais c'est une
vision un petit peu éthérée du passé en
réalité il y avait beaucoup de
difficulté à l'époque aussi ma réponse
est en effet le système sous la
troisième république n'étaient pas
idéales
il y avait plein de choses l'inde
inégalités plein de problèmes mais mais
il y avait une chose qui est
effectivement on a moins aujourd'hui il
faut le dire c'est pas du passéisme
c'est la confiance est là cette
nostalgie que nous avons c'est une
nostalgie de la confiance à mes yeux
donc la confiance est un élément clé à
restituer et c'est pour ça que c'est
tellement important
le genre de choses que vous faites là et
le consensus qu'on est capable de créer
aussi bien localement que nationalement
parce que cette question du processus
d'une société autour de son école bah
c'est un peu comme les parents vis-à-vis
de leurs enfants c'est à dire s'il ya
division ça donne pas de bons résultats
et si la division entre l'école société
école et famille ça ne donne pas de bons
résultats
on a fait une expérimentation qui est
intéressante et qui est bonne
illustration de ce nom nous parlons qui
a été la mallette des parents
la mallette des parents c'est en 2009
dans l'académie de créteil 50 collèges
où on fait des réunions parents
professeurs notamment donc en sixième
ont notamment au premier trimestre pour
familiariser les parents aux enjeux du
collège les devoirs à faire les façon
dont ça fonctionne comment faire réussir
l'enfant etc
et c'est l'étude qui a représenté 1 sur
le plan scientifique un pas dans la vie
l'éducation nationale puisque c'est la
première fois qu'on faisait quelque
chose d'aussi scientifiquement poser
c'est à dire qu'il y avait la fameuse
méthode de la randomisation qui a permis
de mesurer très précisément l'impact de
cette politique et donc on a vu un
impact fort sur le
la présence donc le nom d'absentéisme
des élèves l'affaiblissement de la
violence et même un impact plus léger
mais réel sur les résultats des élèves
et c'est fort de cela qu ensuite quand
j'étais directeur général de
l'enseignement scolaire on l'a élargie à
1300 établissements
ensuite on a fait une autre
expérimentation en troisième pour
l'orientation ça c'était dans l'académie
de versailles
toujours pour étendre et puis dans les
relativement récemment une en cours
préparatoire toujours avec la même
inspiration et là je vois que la
ministre a déclaré que l envisager une
généralisation de ce dispositif
dans le cas des mesures qu'elle envisage
et évidemment je peux trouver que cela
très très positif bien sûr il faut voir
comment et c'est envisagé mais c'est mon
avis tout ce qui a trait à cette
meilleure relation parents établissement
est bon donc ce facteur-là est à est à
souligner comme étant parmi les plus
importants je pourrais évidemment
souligné d'autres mais comme il ya deux
autres questions je je passe à la
deuxième question qui les valeurs
républicaines sont elles suffisamment
inculquer avec commande doit être pensée
l'organisation de l'établissement et et
l'enseignement moral et civique alors
évidemment le contenu de l'enseignement
moral et civique est fondamental parce
que c'est vrai qu'ils ont peut avoir
quelque chose d'un peu artificielle et
est inutile ou voire contre-productif
six années si ce n'est pas bien fait
pour ça moi je pense beaucoup des choses
très simples et et puis aussi aux vertus
de l'exemplarité mais en particulier à
l'école primaire alors on avait en 2011
sorti une circulaire sur l'instruction
morale et civique que honnêtement je
trouve plutôt qui dit plutôt l'essentiel
sur ces sujets là mais ensuite ce que
vincent peillon a pu affirmer était tout
à fait intéressant aussi là aussi il y
aura des continuités de politiques
publiques mais en tout état de cause
l'idée était de 2 d'avoir à l'école
primaire en particulier le rappel
quotidien
deux principes moraux que l'on illustre
par la vie quotidienne des élèves et je
pense que là aussi c'est quelque chose
qui se faisait naturellement à l'école
qui est encore pratiqué d'ailleurs par
beaucoup d'enseignants mais ça n'est pas
généralisé ce n'est pas quelque chose
d'automatique et surtout quand on dit ça
on a peur de passer pour quelqu'un de
nostalgique archaïque des us qui était
absurde s'est littéralement absurde et
sert que quand vous êtes parent vous
faites ça defacto quand vous les éduquer
votre enfant vous fait ce genre de chose
de vie tu regardes le monsieur qui a pas
traverser dans les clous c'est dangereux
fait ce genre de choses donc on ne voit
pas pourquoi on s'interdirait de le
faire en formalisant ça un petit peu la
petite maxine que l'on écrit le matin le
le compte à partir duquel on on tire une
leçon de morale mais qui crée un moment
collectif un moment un petit peu
solenniser pour que les enfants
s'imprègne des principes de respect
d'autrui puisque encore une fois le
respect d'autrui et est fondamentale et
puis ensuite dans les âges plus grand au
collège et au lycée
là je crois beaucoup personnellement à
la à faire vous à rendre plus mûr les
adolescents alors à les responsabiliser
davantage à partir de l'entrée en
sixième
ma conviction sur ce sujet c'est que on
a dans le passage du cm2 en sixième une
une césure qui est toujours souligné
comme un problème avec les enfants qui
ont connu un maître ou une maîtresse
unique
les connaissant bien etc puis ensuite
devant un grand nombre de professeurs
pas forcément bien relier entre eux il
faut atténuer cela c'est ce que
plusieurs ministres successifs ont
cherché à faire et l'ont fait sans doute
insuffisamment mais en tout cas c'est un
sujet qui a un peu progressé au long des
dernières années mais il faut aussi donc
atténuer cette césure en temps l'assumé
c'est à dire que puisque c'est ainsi
puisque de toutes les façons il ya une
école primaire et un collège
eh bien faisons de ce moment une forme
d'initiation républicaine pour pour le
pré adolescent qui entrent en 6e et qui
est encore un peu enfant et un
adolescent en devenir
nous sommes dans des sociétés
sécularisées où il n'y a plus le sacré
dans le coeur du principe des principes
de la république
mais où le besoin d'appartenance est
très fort et peut s'exprimer de manière
non canalisée si je puis dire si la
république n'a pas elle-même fait droit
à ce besoin de sens et donc on souligne
souvent les les éventuels problèmes du
côté du fondamentalisme religieux mais
il ya aussi tout phénomène des gangs
tout le phénomène des ddd des bandes qui
s'organise et qui sont d'une certaine
façon un peu comme on le voit dans
certains pays par exemple cas typique
c'est l'amérique centrale qui sont des
en réalité des phénomènes justement
d'appartenance et que celle quand quand
la collectivité n'a pas assumé le besoin
de sens et de collectivités de l'enfant
que bas que ça que la nature ayant
horreur du vide il va y avoir ce genre
de ce genre de phénomène donc il faut
que le collège le collège n'est pas là
que pour dire
9 heures tu vas faire du français à 10
heures de l'histoire et à 11h des maths
avec on sait bien tout ce que ça
comporte comme côté artificiel et kom
kom kom difficulté à faire sens pour
beaucoup d'enfants
on a besoin je pense au début de la
sixième de rassembler les enfants avec
les professeurs pendant un certain temps
en septembre pour leur expliquer ce qui
ce qui va leur allié à leur arrivée leur
que cela fasse sens qu'on relit les
disciplines que les enjeux moraux et
civique soit explicité et que les enjeux
de devenir de devenir adolescents et
ensuite adultes soit commença est
explicite et qu'on commence à prendre au
sérieux le pré adolescents comme le font
toutes les sociétés depuis toujours
c'est-à-dire il ya un moment donné à
l'adolescence quelque chose qui doit
être un peut s'organiser et nous ne le
faisons plus et si nous ne le faisons
plus d'autres le font donc ça renvoie
aussi à la question de l'organisation de
l'établissement
là je dirai juste deux mots pour dire
puisque c'était votre question que dans
mon introduction j'ai dit à quel point
il fallait faire une communauté unie des
adultes aujourd'hui et ça fait la
transition avec votre troisième question
les organigrammes de l'éducation
nationale sont beaucoup trop souvent en
râteau en gros vous avez le chef
d'établissement la salle des professeurs
pour dire vite là une des clés
d'évolution c'est une gouvernance
beaucoup plus collective un système
beaucoup plus partagés avec des
professeurs qui prennent des
responsabilités à tour de rôle
éventuellement et donc qu'on considère
que l'équipe de direction c'est pas une
personne ou deux personnes ou même trois
mais dix personnes qui sont tels
professeur devenu doyen des lettres tel
autre devenu
responsable des études pour la cie la
classe de 6e c'était l'autre de 5e de 4e
de troisième bref une vraie communauté
responsabiliser et qui permet de faire
le lien avec l'ensemble des professeurs
je pourrais faire des développements
aussi sur le rôle du cdi dans le futur
et comment ils pourraient aussi un lieu
beaucoup plus collectif et beaucoup plus
épanouissant mais en tout cas une
communauté plus soudé tout simplement là
cette communauté la donne l'exemple
ce que je dis n'est ni une utopie ni une
rêverie puisque ça existe en réalité
évidemment et c'est un des éléments
d'optimisme des établissements en france
font ça ou tendre vers cela et
réussissent est l'exemple typique ces
établissements français à l'étranger qui
sont des succès considérables comme on
le sait tous bon évidemment avec des
conditions de température et de pression
différente d'autres établissements mais
néanmoins on voit bien que c'est quand
ses fondamentaux la sont mis en oeuvre
ça ça fonctionne alors la préparation
des enseignants et le soutien de la
hiérarchie et le rôle des inspecteurs
sont ils adaptés par rapport à tout cela
je pense que la réponse est donc non le
sur la sur la formation des professeurs
nous savons bien que que nous nous
poursuivons une amélioration qui n'a pas
encore eu lieu
faudrait en parler longtemps mais des
choses assez schématique ont pu être dit
du tout les cotés sur c'est sur ces
questions le fait est que la situation
n'est pas bonne que le le fait d'avoir
créé les aspects peut être intéressant
parce que le problème c'est pas la
mécanique institutionnelle que l'on créé
parce que par exemple la mécanique iufm
en soi n'était pas une mauvaise chose
pas plus que la mécanique des sp
puisqu'on a en effet bien besoin d'un
lieu de nature universitaire où on
enseigne aux professeurs l'action c'est
ce qui s'y passe pour de vrai et les
personnes que l'on y met pour enseigner
est donc plutôt que de se focaliser sur
ces questions presque le processus qui
sont convenables là tels que ces
formules et aujourd'hui c'est le sait la
question de de qui et quoi s'y trouvent
et là j'ai évidemment que je considère
même si ce n'est pas toujours apprécié
quand je dis que c'est ça qu'il faut
repenser complètement
j'ai insisté au début de mon propos sur
l'importance des sciences cognitives par
exemple je pense que les la pensée de
ceux qui travaillent en sciences
cognitives et très importante et qu'elle
peut avoir un effet en fontaine sur
l'ensemble du système si elle est
réellement pris en compte si on a des
enseignants qui connaissent bien les
enjeux cognitif des enfants et des
adolescents ils sont évidemment plus à
l'aise pour en parler de même je pense
que certains philosophes anthropologues
qui aujourd'hui ne sont pas tellement
étudier dans dans les aspects pourraient
soit avec profit être plus plus étudiée
en tout cas une sorte de de nécessité de
repenser ce qui s'y passe sur le fond et
le type de personne qui enseignent enfin
toujours pour la formation des
professeurs initiale et continue le
continu est extrêmement important des
praticiens c'est quelque chose de très
important est d'avoir des patries sippel
des patriciens et des praticiens
chevronnés dans danser dans ces
établissements
et puis sur le rôle de l'inspection
c'est vrai que aujourd'hui nous avons
une vision totalement infantilisante de
notre système d'ailleurs c'est peut être
un des mots clés de 2,2 ce que je de
l'analyse que j'ai à proposer on a un
système donc infantilisant le de bout en
bout d'un bout à l'autre de la chaîne ça
va de pair avec ce que je disais sur les
organigrammes en râteau c'est infantile
is an pour nous ça maintient l'enfant
dans l'infantilisation si je peux dire
et ça maintient les professeurs dans
l'infantilisation d'où les situations
paradoxales dans lesquelles nous nous
trouvons où on a un système à la fois
très protestataires et en même temps
très hiérarchisée alors qu'on devrait
justement à voir
on devrait avoir l'un vers ce système
qui responsabilise et qu'ils soient
moins protestataires est là et donc ça
c'est évidemment une des grands
mouvements de fond qu'on doit enclencher
et ça est un des éléments pour y arriver
c'est de faire évoluer la fonction
d'inspection c'est dans un sens
complètement différent à la fois pour
bien évaluer l'établissement en tant que
tel donc évaluer davantage la la
communauté l'évolution collective
qu'encore plus que les voeux l'évolution
individuelle est en tout cas l'évolution
individuelle la voir dans un sens qui
soient constructifs pour faire améliorer
les choses en se basant sur les sur les
réussites de l'élève et pas sur une
espèce de conformisme attendu est
souvent très artificielle et
superficielle de la part de l'enseignant
le tour plus pour une gestion des
ressources humaines sans grande marge de
manoeuvre
donc tout ça est un système
assez stérile aujourd'hui qui mérite
d'éviter effectivement une grande une
grande évolution
merci beaucoup monsieur pour ses parents
le vrai je dirais parce que c'est
important pour nous d'avoir des réponses
et des amorces de nouvelles idées chers
collègues j'ai déjà une demande je crois
monsieur kern
on suit voilà on va vous allez prendre
les questions madame trop de lait
monsieur carle et madame pérol dumont
vous prenez toutes les questions pour
pouvoir après répondre dans le temps
imparti si je peux me permettre
merci merci madame la présidente
monsieur blanc clair c'est vrai que
notre rapporteur a déjà posé le
pratiquement toutes les questions qu'on
avait envie de poser mais ne trouvez
vous pas qu'aujourd'hui les référentiels
sont beaucoup trop chargé
avec le temps scolaire un parti pour que
les les enseignants donnent encore une
certaine priorité à enseigner les
valeurs républicaines notamment vous
avez parlé de sept heures de morale
qu'ils ne seraient pas
mas est venu bien au contraire mais
souvent 7h et ola négligent je trouve
parce que justement le référentiel est
trop chargée et un programme les
enseignants répète et un programme il
faut qu'on aille au bout de ce programme
aux maths français histoire géo etc
et puis comment pensez-vous pouvoir
soutenir aujourd'hui les les enseignants
pour affronter justement cette
dégradation du climat scolaire
surtout face aux violences que je
qualifierais beaucoup plus de verbal son
nom parle pas de violence physique mais
des violences verbales des élèves envers
les enseignants sans parler des
violences entre eux au niveau des élèves
est également de la violence verbale des
parents donc vous avez évoqué la
mallette qui je pense est une très bonne
chose mais il ya aussi quelque part mes
enseignants sont aujourd'hui désarmé
face à cette violence
merci madame la présidente très
rapidement deux questions monsieur blanc
caire la première par rapport à
l'intervention que vous avez pu faire
sur l'école maternelle je partage
complètement le fait que l'enseignant
doit suivre l'enfant à la fois dans la
classe et en dehors de la classe parce
que c'est un tout par rapport à cette
sociabilisation vers laquelle on veut le
conduire ma question est la suivante est
ce que vous pensez que les enseignants
sont suffisamment épauler et accompagnés
par les professionnels qu'on met à leur
disposition comme je pense aux
psychologues scolaires etc
et est-ce qu'aujourd'hui ils y font
suffisamment est ce qu'il demande
suffisamment cet accompagnement
deuxième question au niveau du collège
là aussi je partage votre point de vue
l'enseignant aujourd'hui et compte
cantonné dans sa mission de
d'enseignants dans sa classe il y a
effectivement un grand travail à faire
en dehors cette communauté de
professeurs que que vous appelez de vos
voeux qu'ils soient à la disposition des
élèves qui
plus d'interactivité en dehors de la
classe est-ce que vous pensez que cela
pourrait passer par une augmentation du
nombre d'heures parce que nos
enseignants font très peu d'heures dans
les collèges augmentation du nombre
d'heures bien évidemment avec une
rémunération adaptée
mais ce que vous pensez qu'on peut
envisager ceci dans ce contexte là oui
merci madame la présidente de deux
questions vous aussi vous avez parlé
monsieur bancaire de du lien direct
entre le vocabulaire et la violence
effectivement moins on a deux mots plus
on est violent alors comment faire pour
que les jeunes acquièrent le plus tôt
possible
ces mots qu'il hall 1 feront défaut est
ce que ça passe par des mesures d'ordre
pédagogique d'enseignement est ce que ça
fasse pas non plus par une mesure plus
structurelle qui est inscrite dans la
loi jospin de 89
c'est à dire ce premier cycle qui
intègre la dernière la dernière section
de maternelle cp c'est un deuxième
question où il y avait déjà en partie
répondu à la question du rapporteur
concernant ce que j'appellerais le
syndrome de la nation et ce manque de
fierté d'appartenance à la nation reste
que ça devrait pas faire partie
un des maquettes de formation des
enseignants dans ses futures écoles de
formation et puis ce qu'il faudrait pas
remettre l'instar de ce que vous avez
fait un certain moment un certain nombre
de rituels qui vont développer ce
sentiment d'appartenance à la nation
merci à la présidente
oui monsieur le directeur tout d'abord
vous dire combien personnellement
j'adhère et je crois que c'est notre cas
à tous aux rumeurs que vous avez faite
par rapport à notre complexe face à
l'idée de nation dans notre pays je
pense que c'est unanimement partagé
quelles que soient nos appartenances
politiques
nous avons effectivement un problème par
rapport à cette notion-là laquelle pour
autant notre notre pays doit beaucoup et
à laquelle la notion doit beaucoup à
notre pays donc je crois qu'il faut
effectivement que nous fassions notre
révolution culturelle par rapport à ceux
ci c'est le premier point deuxièmement
par rapport à la par rapport à vous avez
dit aussi à travers votre propos en
filigrane mais c'était complètement sous
entendus et je vous en remercie qu'il
n'y a pas un ministre qui ne se soit pas
attacher attaqué à faire évoluer notre
système scolaire
or on voit bien que les choses sont
difficiles la question c'est est-ce que
l'on assigne pas à l'école une mission
qu'elle n'est pas amène seul d'assumer
c'est une question est ce qu'on ne veut
pas faire porter à l'école un certain
nombre d'autres défaillances sociétal
familiales etc
c'est un sujet qui je pense mérite notre
réflexion
il est clair que l'école ne peut pas
tous les enfants y passent un temps
limité et je voudrais simplement pour
preuve la question des registres de
langage les enseignants sont souvent
très choquée par des propos des élèves
qui dans la bouche des élèves ne sont
pas des propos choquants qui sont des
termes naturel dans leur milieu familial
ou dans leur milieu social ou dans leur
quartier donc cette question est une
question fondamentale
autre question que je souhaitais aborder
avec vous vous dites qu'il faut faire
évoluer la fonction d'inspection mais
cette fonction a déjà beaucoup évolué
inspecteur les hyper et à ne sont plus
ce qu'ils étaient il y a trente ans ils
n'en sont plus dans une logique jédir de
suspicion par rapport à l'enseignant ne
viennent pas pour piéger d'abord ils
préviennent à l'avant ce dont ils ont
fait évoluer leurs pratiques
ils se sont souvent entourés de groupe
de formateurs autour d'eux donc on voit
bien que sur le terrain beaucoup
d'expérience existe le décloisonnement
des
un tiers des enseignants de sciences et
de la vie de la terre par exemple
travaillent avec les profs de philo pour
bien montrer le lien qu'il peut y avoir
et montrer qu'il n'y a pas de
cloisonnement dans l'appréhension d'une
culture générale dont beaucoup de choses
se passent
on a plutôt le sentiment que c'est
comment arriver à créer du lien de des
tas de choses intéressantes qui se passe
ici ou là et le fait que finalement on
arrive pas à globaliser tout ça alors je
vais peut-être donné la parole à
monsieur quesnel qui apparemment avaient
quelque chose à rajouter au point où
vous en êtes et je pense lui répond bien
sûr sur ce qu'a dit mama collègues
globalisé et faire durer un certain
nombre d'expérimentations parce que je
crois que le diagnostic que vous avez
émis et j'allais dire la posologie que
vous avez prescrite
moi elle me convient tout à fait mais
problème c'est que ça dure pas en fait à
chaque renouvellement
voilà il ya d'autres idées des
nouveautés etc
les enseignants ne s'y retrouve plus et
c'est une évidence donc comment faire
pour est-ce qu'il faudra interdire que
toute nouvelle réforme vienne dès lors
qu'on a fait l'évaluation de la
précédente et c'est enfin bref comment
faire durer cette posologie pour qu'elle
soit efficace
monsieur blanc caire de répondre à
toutes ces questions en respectant le
temps bien merci pour toutes ces
questions donc je vais répondre dans
l'ordre d'abord sur la question sur le
fait que les référentiels sont sont trop
chargé et qui donc ça laisse très peu de
place aux questions disons de
l'instruction civique et morale
alors comme je le dis en commençant tout
fait système en effet donc
donc forcément on réfléchira à
l'interdépendance des facteurs canton
quand on parle de cela mais d'abord les
questions d'instruction morales et
civiques sont évidemment d'abord et
avant tout des questions transversales
et on doit jeunes s'attacher à voir
comment elles sont présentes dans tous
les dans tous les programmes là en ce
moment on parle beaucoup du latin et du
grec il est évident que si vous étudiez
cicéron il ya des messages d'instruction
civique et morale qui passent comme
monsieur jourdain faisait de la prose si
je puis dire
et puis je fais quand même grande
distinction entre ce qui se passe à
l'école primaire et au collège et au
lycée c'est à l'école primaire s'agit
pas d'y consacrer une heure par jour ce
serait beaucoup trop c'est celle à ce
petit moment un peu solennel peut très
bien durer 5 à 10 minutes et ça peut
être le moment par après chaque
professeur le le voit sa façon mais ça
peut être le moment par lequel on
commence la journée par exemple où le
nom par laquelle on le finit c'est tout
et tout est possible mais c'est ce set
ritualisation qui n'est pas chronophage
du tout qui est souhaitable donc d'une
part transversalité d'autre part
ritualisation sont les réponses qui
permettent de résoudre la question du
temps et je ferai pas développement sur
le sujet des programmes trop lourd et
qui est un véritable sujet mais que
évidemment je n'ai pas le temps de
traiter la
donc je pense que l'aide aussi par
rapport aux 6 es ce que vous avez évoqué
sur un peu la solitude et la difficulté
des professeurs face à la violence en
effet des mécanismes de solidarité
doivent exister pour que jamais un
professeur ne se trouve dans cette
situation de façon seuls y aura toujours
des incidents toujours des parents qui
font des choses surprenantes mais dès
lors qu'on ne se sent pas seul face à
cela une bonne partie du problème est
déjà en voie d'être d'être résolue cela
me paraît essentiel
c'est aussi pas seulement le sujet des
professeurs mais de la communauté
éducative
il ya souvent des solutions qui
apparaissent quand on est bien articulé
avec le tissu social local grâce à
l'ensemble des à l'ensemble des
personnels j'ai beaucoup d'expérience en
tête à l'esprit en vous disant ça j'ai
évidemment pas le temps de rentrer dans
les détails mais mais les solutions
existent et sur cette question comme sur
d'autres
je voudrais et ça rejoint aussi une
question que l'une des questions c'est
là il ya des endroits où ça se passe
bien donc on sait qu il ya des pays où
ça se passe bien il ya des lieux en
france où ça se passe bien à condition
sociale culturelle et géographique
comparables donc c'est bien que c'est
une question est d'ailleurs ces
réjouissances est une question humaine
c'est une question de d'avoir des gens
qui font équipe d'avoir une alchimie
humaine qui se passe bien ce qui passe
en particulier par là c'est la fois la
cause et la conséquence de la pérennité
de l'équipe et ça ça permet donc d'avoir
des réponses
ensuite par rapport à la deuxième
question demain 1,3 md sur les les
enseignants sont-ils est posée épaulé
par dont les enseignants de maternelle
très insuffisamment
et là je pense que ça rejoint team de la
question de monsieur carle tout à
l'heure sur le cycle je fais ce détour
là pour répondre à votre question c'est
à dire je pense qu'on aime moi j'étais
favorable aussi que tel qui les
résultats de la loi 1989 est telle que
vous l'avez rappelé et donc
quand section cp ce1 sachant il se
trouve que ça voilà ça a changé par la
dernière loi crée en raison de votre de
la dernière question vous avez posé sur
la continuité des politiques éducatives
donc l'agent rassemble 3 je ne serai pas
partisan de revenir au point d'abord
parce que parce que justement on va
dérouter tout le monde si on fait sans
arrêt des allers-retours sur ces
questions de 6 qui suppose la conduite
donc il aurait à mon avis mieux valu
qu'on ne change pas mais puisqu'il en
est ainsi c'est une réponse peut-être à
moitié satisfaisant mais puisqu'il en
est ainsi
essayons de jouer le jeu de cette
matériel parce que ça a du sens aussi ça
ça peut se disent tous les deux peuvent
se discuter mais ça a du sens aussi de
considérer la maternelle comme un comme
un tout et là et c'est une des manières
de répondre à votre question parce que
en effet par exemple si on avait dans le
futur un certificat spécifique pour les
enseignants qui enseigne en maternelle
qui s'ajoute à l'ensemble de leurs
compétences et que cela faisait l'objet
d'une formation continue permanente avec
en effet les psychologues qui peuvent
jouer un rôle fondamental je pense au
sujet notamment des enfants handicapés
ou des enfants précoces ou de toutes
sortes d'éléments de différenciation
qu'on doit être capable de faire et pour
lesquelles les enseignants de maternelle
sont insuffisamment formés aujourd'hui
on a besoin d'avoir une petite
spécifique là dessus ça passe notamment
par la certification en maternelle et
l'appui des équipes spécialisées skis et
ski est un sujet anchois en soi et qui
n'existent qu'il n'ait pas organisé
réellement
aujourd'hui ensuite par rapport toujours
me traîner à votre question sur le
nombre d'heures que font les enseignants
à mes yeux c'est un sujet qui doit être
complètement assouplies c'est à dire que
parfois elle fait son enseigne en font
trop parfois ils n'en font pas assez
ça dépend du lieu dont vous parlez de
discipline dont vous parlez des
circonstances c'est des choses qu'on
doit pouvoir juger et donc parfois on a
parlé d' annualisation du temps de
travail pour résoudre ce problème moi
parfois je parle de pluri annualisation
du temps de travail je vais encore plus
loin c'est à dire je considère qu'on
doit avoir une approche en ressources
humaines de ce sera dans l'intérêt de
tout le monde ça peut être gagnant pour
tout le monde c'est à dire qu'un
professeur à certains moments on
pourrait faire beaucoup plus d'heures
passées à d'autres moments beaucoup
moins une appréciation pourrait être
fait de cela en fonction de ce qui fait
qu'ils ne sont pas des heures de classe
et tout ceci donc pourrait faire l'objet
d'une une vision globale à la fois du
parcours de l'enseignant et de la vie de
la collectivité qui serait très
favorable dans si on avait une pelure et
annualisation pourrait envisager des
petits moments sabbatique pomme pour les
professeurs pour qu'ils aillent se
reformer à certains moments si vous nous
mettez trois mois sabbatiques au
troisième trimestre que vous coller aux
vacances d'été
vous avez une vraie période pour se
ressourcer dont parfois certains peuvent
avoir tout à fait besoins et y compris
pour apprendre des choses et c'est donc
il ya c'est plutôt cette vision là que
je défendrai dans ce qui est aussi une
façon d'éviter de dire les enseignants
de travail passaient alors que parfois
les enseignants sur vous ce que vous
n'avez pas dit je voulais que je mets en
tout cas pour éviter de rentrer dans ce
débat qui existe parfois dans le pays
qui sont qui sont qui ne servent à rien
finalement
mais le prendre les choses d'un autre
côté pour améliorer la vie
professionnelle des professeur es et du
coup avoir un impact positif sur sur les
élèves notamment en terme d'implication
collective
ensuite sur la question de monsieur
carle sur le vocabulaire et donc j'ai
commencé à répondre sur le cycle le
oui on peut avoir ce qu'on pourrait
appeler une politique du vocabulaire
je pense que c'est très très important
une petite nation on pourrait parler
d'une politique nationale du vocabulaire
ça passe par les médias en particulier
toute une série de choses volontariste
que l'on que l'on peut faire en la
matière sur le plan pédagogique ça peut
passer par certaines par certaines
approches mais de nouveau le chante la
musique peut jouer un rôle très
important par exemple dans ce domaine
les contes lus à voix haute etc
il ya un programme il y apprend que vous
connaissez je pense qu'ils s'appellent
parler et p ar éleveurs qui a été
d'abord expérimenté à grenoble et à lyon
et puis qu'on a étendu à d'autres zones
qui curieusement d'ailleurs arrêté je le
signale au passage un peu combattue par
l'inspection générale du premier degré
ce que je ne peux que que déplorer le
may 7
ce programme a montré son utilité ils
portent notamment sur sur cela et il ya
un autre programme qui en est dérivé
okaka d'ailleurs aussi exister en
martinique et que l'on appelle par les
bambins et qui peut à exister à la
crèche et j'ai vu d'ailleurs que les
pouvoirs publics avaient souhaité
encourager ces derniers temps et c'est
souhaitable en effet et qui consiste à
stimuler le vocabulaire à la crèche
puisqu'on sait très bien que les enfants
à la crèche va sûrement pas être
considéré comme un objet qu'on compose
là mais comme pelé comme vraiment à un
ide stimulation qu'il faut réaliser et
qui suppose professionnalisme
concentration etc
dans le livre insiste d'ailleurs sur les
méthode montessori de façon générale
pour la maternelle qui vont de pair avec
7 avec cette question là le vous avez
parlé de la dette revenu sur la fierté
d'appartenance nationale et sur les
rituels je crois que ce mot est un des
mots clés en effet les rituels le l'être
humain a besoin de rituel qu'est ce que
la république créée comme rituel c'est
les distributions de par exemple à
créteil on avait fait les distributions
de baccalauréat du diplôme de
baccalauréat là aussi c'est significatif
de ce que ce que vous avez dit c'est à
dire le le fait qu'en france sont soit
pratiquement un des seuls pays où il ya
une si faible solennité de la remise de
diplômes quel que soit le diplôme c'est
un signe de cet affaiblissement de la
sentiment d'appartenance et ritualisé
cela est ritualisée bien des choses dès
l'école primaire
me paraît me paraît souhaitable et c'est
typiquement un sujet de qui pourrait se
définir de façon consensuelle dans le
pays
ensuite par rapport aux questions d'un
pérol dumont le
sur la question de la mission de l'école
qui seraient éventuellement trop large
et c'est évidemment quelque chose qu'on
doit toujours rappeler en effet pour
commencer c'est à dire que c'est
contre-productif de demander de charge
et l'école de plus de mots que que ce
dont elle est responsable parce que
parce qu'on crée des espèces de cercle
vicieux de la du dénigrement alors même
qu'ils se passe des choses
exceptionnelles dans de la part de
l'institution scolaire très souvent et
que ça on le soulignait on ne le
souligne pas assez
et puis par ailleurs votre question on
voit effectivement une vision générale
du rôle de l'école dans la société
alors là aussi je pense que si vous
voulez on peut avoir une conception
qu'on pourrait appeler défensive de
l'institution scolaire en se disant au
fond l'école est un sanctuaire et cette
école sombre sa mission première c'est
l'instruction et il faut faire très
attention ne pas lui demander trop
d'autres choses parce que sinon on lui
demande entre autres choses
on l'a fait rater est ce qu'elle est
censée faire et ce que lui demande de
faire en plus je crois que cette
approche a beaucoup de force et en même
temps on ne peut pas s'en contenter on
est obligé de voir les choses comme
elles sont et de dire de prôner une
approche offensive qui n'est pas
contradictoire avec la précédente mais
qui est plus englobante et qui consiste
à dire une école a un rôle social dans
son environnement
parfois c'est le service public du
territoire concerné
c'est pourquoi d'ailleurs je pense que
des évolutions futures pourraient
consister à donner un rôle à donner des
outils plus important des marges de
manoeuvre plus importante aux chefs
d'établissement dans la mission sociale
autour de l'établissement et qu'il est
un chef d'établissement est un
personnage clé dans dans la franc
offrant enfin dans le nord dans le pays
quoi et donc comment est-ce qu'on
commence qu'en tire toutes les
conséquences de ce de ce constat est
contraint termes de recrutement et de
formation des chefs d'établissement et
donc 7
cette situation fait que il faut assumer
le fait que l'école doit rayonner dans
son environnement et parfois assumer un
peu plus que le temps score un peu plus
que le temps scolaire et donc là on peut
raisonner par cercles concentré que sur
ça c'est tous les enjeux de
l'accompagnement éducatif de 16h à 18h
de des activités périscolaires qui
doivent forcément être coordonnés entre
l'école et les autres acteurs sinon il
ya beaucoup de choses contre productif
qui peuvent se réaliser
et puis à l'extrême il ya évidemment le
sujet des internats qui est un des
sujets les plus chers parce que c'est
quand même la réponse ultime que l'on a
quand on ne maîtrise plus les phénomènes
paix risque extra scolaires qui ont
pourtant un impact sur la vie scolaire
pourrait faire un excellent travail de 8
heures à 17 heures et et ce travail se
défait comme la tapisserie de pénélope
le après 17h et donc les enseignants
peuvent avoir le sentiment de labourer
la mer
face à cela l'institution scolaire à aix
toriques mans une réponse cette réponse
c'est que c'est l'internât non pas comme
un phénomène de fuite ou de
déresponsabilisation de la famille parce
qu'on peut avoir tout à fait l'internât
est associé l'association de la famille
ce qui se passe au travers de l'internât
moi j'ai vu avec l'expérience des
internats d'excellence est vraiment d un
lien avec la famille s'affirmer grâce à
ça parce que le avec des familles qui
des parents qui pourrait dire
explicitement
je ne lâche pas du tout mon enfant je
vous le confirme c'est vrai que la
situation a atteint certaines limites et
c'est et je vous fais confiance et
ensemble on va avoir un projet éducatif
commun et ça c'est évidemment
extrêmement extrêmement important voilà
pour cette audition sur le thème de
l'éducation et la perte de repères
républicain la commission d' enquête à
ce sujet au sénat
auditionné ce matin jean michel blanquer
directeur général du groupe essec et
ancien directeur général de
l'enseignement scolaire au ministère de
l'éducation nationale devant les
sénateurs il est revenu sur ses
propositions il insiste notamment sur le
rapport de l'enfant à l'autre et à
l'ensemble du groupe et sur l'importance
des relations avec les parents d'élèves
vous pouvez toujours voir et revoir
cette audition et toutes les autres sur
notre site publicsenat.fr
très bonne suite des programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires